Does hand and foot size really correlate with
penile length
Given that public nudity is generally considered
unacceptable in most of the modern world (and
if you’re wondering, see: When Did Humans
Start Wearing Clothes?), people have long
tried to come up with other potential indicators
to determine the size of a guy’s manhood
without actually seeing it.
A seemingly tried and true method for doing
just this is to look at the size of the man’s
hands and/or feet.
But does hand and foot size really correlate
to the length of the penis?
Nope.
Studies have consistently shown that the size
of a guy’s feet or the overall size of their
hands is not related to their member’s erect
measurement.
However, a man’s fingers do give a strong
clue as to their probable penis size- but
the overall length of the fingers is not what’s
important here.
For instance, a study published in the Asian
Journal of Andrology in 2011 found that the
ratio between the 2nd and 4th digits on the
hands strongly correlates with the overall
length of an individual’s penis.
Specifically, Dr. Ho Choi and et al. state;
Univariate and multivariate analysis using
linear regression models showed that…. only
digit ratio was a significant predictive factor
for stretched penile length…
fingers2In a nutshell, the lower the ratio-
how much shorter the index finger is than
the ring finger- the longer the penis will
probably be when erect.
(And if you’re wondering, flaccid penis
length is not an accurate predictor of erect
penis length.)
More specifically, you can calculate your
ratio by taking the length of your index finger
(measured from the crease where it meets your
hand, to the tip) and divide it by the length
of your ring finger.
The shorter your index finger is compared
to the ring finger, the lower the ratio will
be and, if you’re a man, the longer your
penis probably is.
So why does the ratio of the index and ring
finger lengths correlate to erect penis length?
In the beginning, female and male genitals
are pretty much the same.
This is because they develop from the same
cluster of tissues (gonads).
In males, somewhere around weeks 7-9 of gestation,
the gonads begin secreting two hormones- Anti-müllerian
hormone (AMH) and testosterone.
AMH prevents the development of the ducts
that eventually turn into the fallopian tubes,
the uterus, and upper vagina.
Once the gonads begin secreting testosterone,
some if it (around 5-10%) gets transformed
into another hormone called dihydrotestosterone.
Both testosterone and dihydrotestosterone
will attach to androgen receptors, which affect
the growth and development of many different
body systems.
Notable here, dihydrotestosterone attaches
to androgen receptors on tissues that eventually
develop and combine into the penis and scrotum.
Low levels of this within the womb, or later
during puberty, may result in an underdeveloped
or malformed penis.
So to sum up here, penile growth in the womb
is stimulated and affected by testosterone,
dihydrotestosterone, and androgen receptors.
Circulating amounts of the two hormones, combined
with the associated androgen receptor stimulation,
will determine penis size.
So what about fingers?
Circulating testosterone in the womb will
affect other body parts as well- pertinent
to the topic at hand, including the ratio
between the 2nd and 4th digits (index and
ring fingers).
Why does testosterone affect digits differently?
For that, I’ll have to get a little more
technical, but essentially the activity mediated
by androgen receptors, and estrogen receptor-a,
is higher in your ring finger compared to
your index finger.
This is regulated by the structure of genes
controlling the process for the bone growth
of your fingers, called endochondral ossification.
The spread of chondrocytes will determine
the length of your finger, and this expansion
is higher in the ring finger compared to the
index finger.
When you decrease the activation of androgen
receptors during the narrow window of digit
development (usually completed by week 13
of gestation), you will decrease the length
of your ring finger.
This activation is attributed to amount of
testosterone and DHT circulating throughout
the tiny fetus.
Conversely, if you decrease the activity of
the receptor estrogen-a (the ones being stimulated
more when you’re female), you will get a
longer ring finger.
Based on this physiology, it has been long
known that you can predict prenatal hormone
exposure based on the ratio of these two fingers.
Since both penile length and the ratio of
the ring and index finger is basically a result
of the amount of testosterone and DHT circulating
in utero, there is a correlation between that
ratio and the length of a man’s favorite
appendage.
As you might have guessed from all this, the
ratio between the lengths of one’s index
and ring fingers is usually quite different
in men and women- men tend to have shorter
index fingers than ring fingers; women tend
to have their index fingers either the same
length or longer than their ring fingers.
Penile length isn’t the only thing digit
ratio can predict.
Since testosterone and DHT control the development
of several body systems and processes, digit
ratio can be a predictor of a wide range of
physiological and psychological conditions.
These include things like athletic ability,
sexual orientation, fertility, and some sex
based ailments such as prostate and uterine
problems.
Lower digit ratios tend to occur in people
with more aggressive behaviors, and those
with them are less likely to suffer from eating
disorders.
People with higher digit ratios tend to be
more agreeable.
Research has also indicated that straight
women and gay men who have higher ratios tend
to prefer partners who are more masculine.